welcome to today's live broadcast title
glycated hemoglobin for diagnosis and
monitoring of diabetes current practice
I'm Dave robberies thorough clinical
chemist at Emma diagnostics and I have
the privilege of being the moderator for
today's event this webinar is held in
conjunction with world diabetes day 14th
of November 2015 to highlight that
growing concerned with the health threat
posed by the global diabetes epidemic
and it recognized a central role the
clinical laboratory plays in diagnosis
diagnosing and monitoring diabetic
patients today's webcast is presented by
lab routes comm the leading social media
site for science professionals and it is
sponsored by abba diagnostics before we
start there a few instructions we want
to hear from you during this interactive
broadcast so please ask questions or
leave us a comment you can do this by
hitting the green Q&A button at the
lower left of the presentation window
and typing in your comments and
questions we'll try to get to as many as
we can and will follow up but we don't
have time to do so today you can enlarge
the slide window by clicking on the
screen icon in the lower right hand
corner of a slide window if you can't
hear or see this presentation properly
let us know by clicking on the support
button on the top right or use the Q&A
button will try to resolve any issues
this webinar has been approved for
accent continuing education credits from
the American Association for clinical
chemistry please click on the c/e button
at the bottom left corner and follow the
process to receive your your credits
it's my pleasure to introduce our first
speaker professor gary john of the
Norfolk and Norwich University Hospital
in the United Kingdom where he is the
head of clinical biochemistry and
immunology professor John is an expert
in diabetes and glycated hemoglobin and
served as the chair of the ICC's working
group on standardization of hemoglobin
a1c is currently the chair of the ICC's
task force on implementation of hba1c
standardization
dude thank you for induction and is
great pleasure to speak to everybody
today about hemoglobin a1c is
biochemistry and measurement there's no
doubt that the greatest advance in this
study of diabetes was the introduction
of insulin back in the early 1920s but
the great challenge for us in
laboratories is now how can we monitor
it like seemly control in our patients
with diabetes here we can see young
Leonard Thompson before and after the
first injection of insulin the big move
for us to the ball trees or the
description by rubber in 1968 was
brought to the notice of the medical
ternity what he then called an abnormal
hemoglobin in the bed cells of diabetics
but indeed it will overtake it earlier
that this fraction was first described
by Hank l and woloson where they
actually described a new fraction with a
turn hemoglobin a 100 many years sisters
this description a number of researchers
have elucidated exactly what is
happening in the biochemistry of this
faction let's look at this reaction
sequence all proteins will react with
glucose as long as the glucose is in the
open chain format almost all the
proteins in the body glucose will react
the lysine residue unlike now the
proteins hemoglobin is different where
glucose will react to the end
Baylen rather than the lysine slow music
aliquots is in the open chain format the
protein will reversibly reality goes
following a double bond this faction is
called a ship this if he early kinkos
reform the ring structure no further
reaction will take place this reaction
is fully reversible and kids part over a
number of hours the next stage of the
action is now Midori rearrangement this
is almost irreversible reaction although
these days we realize that reaction is
slightly reversible cure the double
Gordon moves the position of a tool to
position number one and this stabilizes
the fraction and once formed kito arin
ingram a1c is stable within the blood
sample the second reaction takes place
over a number of games so here we can
see the full reaction in complex
reaction not as straightforward as we
see in textbooks but once formed the key
terrain is stable this is a non
enzymatic reaction and follows the law
of mass action given is the kinetics of
reaction the first reaction formula
shift pays you can see is fully
reversible the fold in iraq and reverse
reaction show you the same kinetics
whereas the second reaction from
ship-based aikido a lien is almost
irreversible if you look it up
slightly further legal is buying two
proteins and if the protein has got a
short half-life the animal product is
formed by the ship this this decay is
the things like hemoglobin and albumen
but what approach is it got a longer
half-life well then a further reaction
takes place for men advanced ligated end
products these are highly reactive
substances and may actually form the
basis of some of the complications
relating the diabetes I will no I will
not talk about these any third of the
day because that would be a lecture in
its own right so what assumptions we
have to make if we got our 20 encima
global narrow and see to monitor the
ICBM we have you seen mr. McLaughlin is
present at a constant concentration
within individual is it probably true
but what about anemia never seen the
lifespan of the red blood cells a
constant again with an individual this
is probably true but may not be true
between individuals will presume that
micro environment is constant again Lynn
an individual is it probably true if all
these assumptions are true bengali goes
is only bearable and because this is a
non enzymatic reaction for the law of
mass action if the phone the formation
of hemoglobin a1c is the product of
glucose concentration but our de
sumption is true well is interesting we
have little evidence or information what
effect and leme your hands on the
hemoglobin a1c we know or we think we
know that I'm deficiency has an effect
of increasing hemoglobin a1c but in a
recent systemically reveal we have seen
the live a little evidence around this
it is just fine deficiency wyzant
efficiency and anemia you don't know
unless film
looking at what about the red life span
well according to school we always
taught that red cells have a lifespan
120 days well that is true for large
extent they says they are they unlike
this fight much beyond and 20 days but
there is a large barrel in the life span
of red cells both live in individual and
also mainly between individuals because
he hears some work done by a popcorn at
all when you seen that if you collect
the life span of ourselves in patients
work of the same glycemic level we can
correct hemoglobin a1c measured good
evidence that red cell survival had to
direct an important effect on the
measured hemoglobin a1c so does this
mean in real life where you have two
patients both that tentacle glycemic
control identical mean glucose within
their bodies but can be king single or
may want to see values that are there is
ends of the population range hemoglobin
a1c so patient one here has got
identical nicely control to patient tool
but a very much different him prevalence
see unless we shown quite nicely in the
a dike studied published in davines
carrington sub sanity when he willnae 1c
relates directly to average glucose but
when we look at different patients we
can see that hemoglobin a1c of eighty
percent believes to arrange illegals
values mint legal sullivan different
patients from robert 8.1 and Billy was
leader of a 12 point 1 billion was
bleedin showing that Betty shield
between individual variation
in what the glycemic levels are the same
hemoglobin a1c also you can see here
some work done by Andrea mosca and
co-workers that the variability within
individuals is quite small Mayor was a
[ __ ] seizure on these dots individual
subjects and the variation neutral
maewyn see around the volumes vehicles
are non-diabetic individuals do you see
that the male values actually Larry
quite small amount but in a seizure that
in females variation is much larger we
have no evidence to know why this is but
it is interesting also what is being
measured we always told that hemoglobin
a1c represents the mean glycemia
invasions the last three months or so
well that is true but by far the
greatest influence on results you obtain
it within a month before the bed sample
is collected you see here in a blood
sample collected at the end of may
thirty two percent of the influence of
that result comes from the glycemia
within a 27-percent nail probe and only
about five percent from the glitter I
see me control or the blessing level
three months or four months earlier so
yes nuloom a1c does represent a glycemic
control over the period of the red cell
lifespan but the major influence is in
the preceding one month what would
methods for measuring him Phil Nevin
seeing well like in 1958 I'll let out is
rather large column for separating off
this newly found him to a one but these
columns are over a meter long and
required one liter of
and two separate often ultimate love
near one well a clinical work is never
going to be an option you can imagine
for botanist saying only another half
liter of blood then you can measure you
look real and see luckily these days
methods have been designed and described
that allow us to measure hemoglobin a1c
in a clinical situation but there are a
number of major method principles
three-line charge separation when
hemoglobin binds to glucose at the end
table dalene it creates a very slight
charge difference Alima globin trimble
of Naval Sea can be separated me from
any node is also structural difference
obviously glucose we're finding little
been traces slight difference in the
structure of the molecule and also their
chemical differences there are large
number of HPLC methods that described
and this is probably the longest use
methyl group inc little medicine
capitola the fleeces relatively meal
with the same method piss-poor charge
separation but mega pillory rather than
on a column affinity chromatography this
method recognizes the glucose moiety of
hemoglobin a1c and uses a parodic acid
to bind the systems of the glucose the
human with Luca was it finally colon a
Lincoln don like 80 little bit wash it
off in then leaves a different offer to
war shortly glycated hemoglobin is
interesting at the washing off of the
hemoglobin is in reverse to dusk by
ion-exchange chromatography immunoassay
glucose bound lima globin traces
slightly different structure and
therefore an antibody can be raised
against the slight difference
large number of universities have
described the new method recently
described is enzyme clearancing this is
where an enzyme is used to recognize the
int'l near 1c and also don't forget
there are a large number of point of
care systems available for measurement
of implored near on the scene so one
stands ations so important well as I've
already said there are large number of
different method principles available
for measuring Kingdom agency can't an
exchange chromatography completely
decreases affinity separation me to
answer enzymatic and also around the
world there are over a hundred different
methods and platforms available at all
the 20 international manufacturers
already consider national manufacturers
than many many more so let's look back
the late 70s and early 80's things were
not looking good not only were fashioned
poor but let's look at hemoglobin a1c
results we were saying there was a large
difference between results of paying
different laboratories around the UK and
these CDs relate to a difference in
measured hemoglobin a1c from about 4.4
4.3 to about nine and a half percent
even see this range and results not
except for clinical use especially when
we assume that if one of the scent
change in hemoglobin a1c as measured in
the dcct and ukpds studies show that a
one percent difference can lead to a
twenty one percent improvement in deaths
related diabetes a thirty-seven percent
improvement in microvascular
complications
at fourteen percent improvement in my
car turn my car gel in falcon so methods
with this level of difference are not of
any clinical use this lack of
standardization and agreement in results
as led to a number of comfort countries
developing their own standards ation
program probably the most notable of
these is the NGS p system in america
they're also the Swedes the Swedish and
the Japanese had their own calibration
systems but there was a problem with
this religious programs basically norm
use it through reference method and
there was no primary reference material
to anchor the results for stable
long-term revisa build in the NDP
network was a good concept it uses
Center primary rest of the poetry using
a reference message which was a
reference method at the time when it was
first described by go cena del back in
the early 1960s but this was not a true
a reference method I would intercede
with by a number of interference this
primary reference aboard for you then
standardized in number of second
addresses of all trees and the second
arrest of the poor trees were then use
to standardize clinical methods used in
our laboratories it was a great concept
as I say but there was no primary
material to calibrate this hplc and also
the hplc which was state-of-the-art back
in the nineteen eighty-six
was no longer recognized as a true
reference method but you can see the
large improvements that were achieved by
introduction of the NGOs p harmonization
program you can see here the range
results fell in laboratories around the
u.s. in nineteen nineteen ninety-three
improve dramatically over the years to
2010 but the range results achievable
aboard please it knows so much better
but modern-day practice of clinical
biochemistry requires methods to be
standardized to a metrological standard
other requirements for mex logical
standard asians are identification of
the measure and the production of a
reference measurement procedure restless
material primary refs material and
laboratories that can be used this
method to actually standardized sofla
balti methods had also results to be
traceable back from the patient sample
to the reference measurement procedure
the ifcc recognized this short coming in
stand the nation of immigrants aim
uninformed a working group with the
briefs to actually produce a reference
measurement procedure and rathod
material feeldog raehwan seen this will
group worked hard over a number of years
and he ignis years working hard in a
local hostelry here in norfolk but
seriously this was a daunting task but
after several years of work a reference
mention procedure was described
unpublished and rasmus material were
produced reserves ended pure hemoglobin
a note and punitive an a1c which pretty
used to calibrate the primary reference
method
I'm based in this work we have now got
here traceable train from a patient
sample right back by an unbroken chain
of events to the primary reference
material the pure hemoglobin a1c and the
pure hemoglobin a note the problem arose
of course that the new reference mesh
procedure film called me when see
described by the ifcc was different in
results to those obtained by the
national societies as his be released an
addition screams and now is because the
ifcc arrested procedure was specific for
hemoglobin a1c where are the other
methods part interferences in May method
so then the question was asked what
should we report him little maven see
and what units will be using percent is
not a recognized measurement unit so the
ifsc see are you pal committee looked at
the molecule and decided that it should
be reported in SI units and the SI unit
simple a1c is milli more two more ie the
limo of hemoglobin a1c term all
hemoglobin a naught plus hemoglobin a1c
of course these results would be
different to those can be reported in
percent units to try identify what
needed to be done and what changes need
to be brought about the ifcc met with
the clinical diabetes association's the
American Diabetes Association the
european association to study diabetes
hungry the International Diabetes
Federation to discuss how results should
be measured and reported around the
world
they came up with a consensus statement
and the two major parts of the consensus
of Hyla did year and those are the ifc
see a reference system imguruen see is
the only valid anchor for which method
around the world should be standards
against and also the hemoglobin a1c
results should be reported worldwide in
IFE SI units or SI units limit more and
derived n gfp units the sent using the I
FEC and jazz be master equation with a
show you earlier but I will not talk
much more than evasion I will leave this
to dr. Wright camp who will be talking a
little later on so what the challenges
we now face to the new century well the
early diagnosis of type 2 diabetes is by
far the greatest challenge we have
around the world now there are over 360
million people who have diabetes but by
2030 this number will have risen
dramatically to over 550 million people
and possibly the most worrying thing is
that over half the patients with
diabetes will go undiagnosed unless we
can go out and look for these patients
and why is this dramatic increase in
diabetes happening well obesity is one
of the main issues we see is globally in
clinical medicine these days here we can
see the direct relationship between
waist size on this thickness of your TV
so why is the pc happening well it is
the availability of cheap high-calorie
food did you see her a big breakfast in
a cafe I would like to say in America
but this is a cafe 30 miles from a
hospital here in the east of england and
all
food it available relatively 15 pounds
or nineteen dollars and it'll eat all
that food and I doubt where many of
those could it's free so it's not
surprising that obesity is a major issue
and a major problem globally these days
so diagnosed diabetes type 2 diabetes
that is then the moon to type II
diabetes is not an instantaneous event
it is a continuum ranging from normal
glycemia so this glycemia in the
diabetes and currently where we guide
those diabetes is where we have an
increase in the frequency of
microvascular complications so we had
died of diabetes at this point here to
improve the outcome we try and move that
diagnostic criteria down the line so it
diagnosis people earlier a diagnosis
little earlier we will limit the
development of micro and macro vascular
complications at this end the wh 0
recommended in 2011 that hba1c should be
used the diagnosis of diabetes report
for some caveats that the needs be
stringent quality assurance systems in
place before disease and also that the
arteries are standardized to the
International reference values for this
to happen of course message need we
standardized to the I FCC restaurant
system as as was stated in the consensus
statement it is the only anchor there is
solid the standard asian of hemoglobin
a1c so will improve things well it'd be
beautiful because if we look at a fixed
point five percent or 48 million more
sperm or cut off but diagnosed diabetes
patients already have significant
macrovascular complications high number
of cargo vessel
these stroke and talk mortality I think
Reese already at that time so I think
over time we will need to actually look
at the value of the cutoff throw methods
that we use and both we are they are
treating us well I figure this way we
now have that I FCC reference mesh
receive the stands ation I can look at
this at the atomic clock a carib for one
second is 30 million years but there are
abroad trees we have our routine methods
and no matter how good those methods are
they can open the layer of the results
we produce are only as good as a method
we use so it is said of accuracy but the
quality of the methods we used in
laboratories is still ultimately the
most important thing an accuracy is
important with look at this graph here
this shows hemoglobin a1c results in an
undiagnosed group of Americans in u.s.
census population these people are not
known to be diabetic briefly look here
eight point one percent or one milli
more per mole difference in the results
result in about 1 million people being
wrongly diagnosed in real life for this
means well this little recent return
from the cap survey where we look at
chemical vagrancy results returned
around America this is all cheer could
result it from this message loop 45
million most the law six point two eight
percent ranging up to 52 min immortal or
six point eight eight percent and this
is interesting because the mean value
was 6.5 the center 40 no more memos the
mall they kept on the diagnosis there
are seven million or more difference
here on
% how many people will be wrongly
diagnosed error across the u.s. with
this range of results also within
medicals themselves we find results that
are at the show good accuracy but the
variability around the accuracy is far
too great we also find results are both
inaccurate and emphasize we must work to
actually stop using these methods to the
finish I just want to point out that
even though click illimitably 1c relate
to each other they do not equal each
other the general population glucose
concentration does not equal hemoglobin
a1c and diagnosis of glucose did not
equal diagnosis The Improv nuin see they
are different and how to be treated
differently let's look at particular
patient here we go 50 year-old male with
a history of heart disease he had a
[ __ ] legalism because the general
practitioner looking at this patient
thought he may actually have diabetes
the fat equals 6.3 million oscillator 1
13 milligrams per deciliter and my
laboratory reported this as impaired
fasting life senior the GP whistle
concerns so repeated the sample
achievements later on the sets of
december two thousand twelve this I
think Lincoln's of 6.6 millimoles per
liter 119 milligram per deciliter and if
hemoglobin a1c was 47 million was the
mall not quite reaching the six north
descent cutoff for diabetes again
malavalli reported this as impaired
sizing glycemia the gpro satisfied and
repeated it again they shows how good my
glucose method is 6.5 millimoles per
liter 117 milligrams per deciliter again
in pets I think I senior
so GP decided with tolerance has been
patient the fasting kligos was 6.9
million Mo's felita again impaired by
things like Syria but the to our value
was sent in Point nine-millimeter 322
milligrams death misses a definite
diagnostic criteria for diabetes but is
this patient diabetic or not that is the
question the following month for a year
hemoglobin a1c catch the six point five
percent cut level for diabetes this goes
to show that a diagnostic criteria for
hemoglobin a1c answer glucose diagnose
different individuals I hope I've shown
you even though with a technical glitch
in the middle that the management of
hemoglobin a1c is not so straightforward
but message villains are improving all
the time and soon our ability to
diagnose diabetes earlier in our
patients will be of value thank you
Thank You professor John our second
speaker is dr. caso I can director dmca
laboratory of the queen beatrix hospital
in the Netherlands dr. Watkins a
globally recognized authority in
hemoglobin a1c standardization and
certification is the network coordinator
of the ICC CEO of an a1c reference
method system and responsible for the
worldwide standardization of hemoglobin
a1cs a did that thank you David for
introducing me I'm going to talk today
about quality targets for hba1c with
focus on diagnostic use what we don't
realize often in the laboratory that we
are the cornerstone for the treatment
and for diagnosis of diabetes and in
combination with the fact that diabetes
is a chronic disease with the higher
prevalence we can imagine that lab tests
are extremely important higher
prevalence we can imagine that lamp has
orlich so hba1c requires the highest
quality hba1c requires the Hyneman so
the highest quality of hba1c it starts
with standardization and then you can
require what and why standardization
when you standardize you get equal
results irrespective well in any
laboratory anywhere in the world or
manufacturer who have equal results once
you have achieved that you have uniform
interpretation the same clinical
guidelines the same clinical decision
limits the same literature that's very
convenient the benefits is reliability
patient safety comes first
but as dr. Graeme be so past president
of the ifcc stated there are many more
points why we should standardized for
example but my confidence patient self
safety clinical governance then comes
the question how to standardize well for
hba1c as Gehringer already pointed out
there are many method principles hplc
affinity chromatography etc and for each
method principle there are many many
manufacturers and that implies that you
get many different results when you
don't standardized and this there was
awareness already 20 30 years ago and
there were national initiatives to
standardize in the US best-known the NGS
p but also in japan and scandinavia
unfortunately when you compare the
national reference systems it appears
that the analytical anchor is
arbitrarily chosen they are not specific
therefore you get different numbers that
causes a lot of confusion and then the
ifcc came in and said this is
unacceptable we want someone to develop
a scientifically sound reference method
as the ankle to achieve worldwide
harmonization of hba1c and that's what
happened I won't go through the whole
thing but the concept of the
traceability of the traceability chain
was adopted it starts with a definition
of the analyte then you have a primary
reference measurement procedure with
which you assign values to the primary
calibrator and that primary calibrator
is used to calibrate the secondary
reference measurement procedure etc and
at the bottom of the traceability chain
you have the routine laboratory your
laboratory and a patient sample
this has become an approved reference
methods already 30 years ago so it was
in place to warrant that there is access
throughout the world it was necessary
that the iacc reference method was
operated all over the world and by now
we have a network of laboratories doing
this as you can see in Europe in the
Americas and in Asia quite recently 3rd
Chinese laboratory joined the network
and there is still one candidate and
it's quite something when laboratory
passes the criteria of the ifcc network
time to celebrate in this network we
have a special batch of champagne which
we hand out in the laboratory that
gained the status of an approved
laboratory here the Shanghai laboratory
three years ago also to maintain the
quality of the network laboratories we
have a technical meeting once a year
here you see a photo of the group taken
this year at Euro matlab in Paris once
the IFC see reference method was in
place we thought that the work was done
but it wasn't true definitely enough for
there was a debate on hba1c numbers and
everything every time when there is a
change there are three kind of people
purists conservatives and strategist and
that was also the case with the hba1c
the purists I'm one of them they say
well we have this is you see reference
system now also use the units and
patient reports do it but the
conservatives have an opposite view they
say well keep your dcct numbers
physicians are used to it patients are
used to it never change a winning team
that's the prevalent view
in the US and then there are strategists
in this case the I FCC and the important
international diabetes organizations
they concluded it must come a consensus
statement and that is what happened
essential as Gary John already pointed
out is that the iacc reference method is
the analytical anger for hba1c but hba1c
should be reported in patient reports in
I FCC and NTSB units so that's the world
today international we have distances in
kilometers temperature in degrees
Celsius and hba1c in millimole per mole
and in the u.s. you have miles
Fahrenheit and percentage hba1c we
simply have to live with it fortunately
as I FCC Network coordinator I have a
good relation with any little the NGO
speed network coordinator and twice a
year we exchange samples between both
networks to be sure that the master
equation this is the equation to convert
from mg sp2 I FCC and vice versa is
still correct and at the bottom you see
this equation also dual certification I
FCC and NGS be so we have achieved full
standardization in the world for hba1c
and indeed we have Universal
interpretation guidelines set up a go
below 53 millimole per mo etc the total
system is in place now the IFC see
reference method at the bottom is used
to assign values to the IFC see
collaborators and those calibrators are
supplied to all manufacturers of hba1c
kids and those manufacturers use the
collaborators to assign values to
kit calibrators you use in your
laboratory also you participate in a
proficiency test program or an external
quality assessment program and the
samples you get from your eq apt
organizers have target values assigned
with the ifsc see reference method and
when there is a perfect match you will
see you have a good score in your PT
scheme and then you can say that is
perfect match then we have teeth what we
want uniform clinical guidelines
reliable results patients and
diabetologists can rely on what we are
doing in the laboratory and the efforts
of the standardization people at the
manufacturers of you and the laboratory
resulted in a dramatic improvement of
the quality in my eq a program I have
seen that 20 years ago the infant
laboratory CV so the between laboratory
CV was thirty-three percent and last
year it dropped to three percent a
dramatic improvement of quality and
because quality of hba1c improved that
much there's also a change in paradigm
hba1c is not only used anymore for
monitoring but also for the diagnosis of
diabetes and that's quite something
hba1c gold standard for hba1c where
previously it was the fasting plasma
glucose or the glucose tolerance test
not everybody agrees there is discussion
about it and that is explained by the
small differences in the range of hba1c
when you look at the graph you see that
with an hba1c below 40 you have a low
risk to have or to develop diabetes and
only at slightly higher values at 40
many more per mo or higher you have
diabetes and there is a small range from
40 to 47 where there is an increasing
risk for diabetes so you can imagine the
small error has a high impact on
interpretation and the error in your
laboratory can derive from bias due to
wrong calibration or from imprecision
when the reproducibility is not very
good in your laboratory let's have a
closer look the impact of buyers on
interpretation say you have a sample
with a true value of 44 millimole per MO
and you have no bias and you'll ability
you find exactly the correct value and
the interpretation is correct increasing
risk but when you have a positive bias
of four millimole per mole you will
report value of 48 millimole per mole
and a physician will conclude this
patient has diabetes on the opposite
when you have a negative bias of four
millimole you will report a value for T
millimole per mole that implies that the
physician will conclude no risk for this
patient so quite wrong conclusions from
wrong numbers then the impact of
imprecision on interpretation again you
have the same sample with the true value
of 42 millimole per mole when you say
this sample say 20 times in your
laboratory and you have a CV of one
percent each of these assay results will
be within a very narrow range all
allowing the same conclusion increasing
risk of diabetes when the CV of your
essay is 2% still quite acceptable when
it goes up to four percent you can
expect values in the same sample that
are even in diabetic or in a low-risk
range and that's not very good for him
to interpretation so
this new application of hba1c the use
for diagnosis led to new awareness of
quality and the iacc task force on hba1c
has an important mission statement and
that is to develop model for quality
criteria and that's what we have done
and we follow the concept of Sigma
matrix there are two things that you
should define when you apply this model
first an allowable error what do you
allow what is the maximum error you
allow in your laboratory and this task
force we set a default value of five
millimole per mole or you say I want to
be sure that the result I report from my
laboratory is not different more than 5
million mole per mole from the true
value and the second thing that is
defined that the risk of not meeting the
criterion and we serve as I FCC task
force it is acceptable that one out of
20 results doesn't mean defined
criterion I want to stress that these
are default settings we are an
international organization and can't say
to all organizations at the national
level you can do it it's up to local
authorities to adopt these default
settings or to set more or less
stringent criteria but the model can be
used irrespective the criteria an
explanation not in mathematics but in
the graph you make a plot of the
imprecision and bias the buyers on the
y-axis in concentration units so you can
plot the buyers or 1234 millimole and on
the x-axis the imprecision in cv hamed's
from one to five percent and the line is
from five mil immoral for more bias to
five percent imprecision so creating
triangle
when dots are within the triangle that's
your performance so that means you are
within the criteria of the iacc when you
have point dot outside the triangle and
it means that you are without outside
the criteria two examples to demonstrate
the extremes where you can just pass
here you see an example of laboratory
represented by the heart this laboratory
has a CV that is excellent near zero
percent but the buyers are formally more
per mole that's just good enough to pass
and here you see the other example
hardly any bias but a high CV and that
is also just good enough to pass the
criteria now we come to the application
of the model you can apply the model and
the individual laboratory you can do it
in your laboratory you can also apply it
at the country level or at the
manufacturer level and I will show
several examples let's start with the
country level say Barack Obama wants to
know and asks when I have my hba1c is
said in any laboratory anywhere in the
US can I expect the DIFC seed criterion
is met you can take that information
from the cap survey about 3,000
liberties participate in it and you can
plot the bias the mean of all those
laboratories in the US and you can also
plot the between the buret or ecv in the
u.s. of all those 3,000 liberties and
then you will see this is the cap survey
of 2014 that there was a mean bias of
all laboratories about 1 million mobile
mo and between laboratory CV
four percent and IFC four percent in ng
SB and six percent in IFC SI units so
clearly outside the IFC see criteria we
can also have a look at the manufacturer
level Obama is not satisfied he says
okay so in general we don't meet the
criteria why is def is there any
relation with the methods or with the
manufacturers and also those data you
can take from the cab data that's done
in this figure what i have done is a
plot of groups of users that using the
same method of a manufacturer each dot
represents a group of men group of
laboratories using the same method for
example they are bioroid users of their
total users or they are ever juices etc
dots represents the bullet or
instrumentation squares represent
point-of-care instruments green or
immunological methods rent our ion
exchange methods yellow is affinity
chromatography and blue is the capillary
electrophoresis and you see quite a
difference in performance between the
methods about half of them are within
the triangle implicating that all the
bodies using those methods are
successful in performing well the other
half of the methods is outside criterion
for example when you look at the red
dots of the U and W those are typically
methods well calibrated well
reproducible with an imposition of
approximately two percent but quite a
high bias and that high bias causes that
this group of laboratories is outside
the criteria
when you go to dot a green right below
the opposite hardly any bias but the end
of the bar between the Berkeley cv is
quite high and then the pool is
performance is for the methods sr t and
oh they have all they have my bias and
the pool imprecision and they are far
outside now obama wants to know what
about innovative efforts of
manufacturers any progress over time and
the answer is yes this is a typical
example this is the cap survey one cycle
later and you see that one of the
manufacturers of srt started with a new
method the enzymatic method and that
performance is doing very well in the
cap survey is the purple dot so
improvement is possible and when it
happens at a large scale with all
manufacturers i'm quite sure that the
performance overall performance will
come within the criteria when you want
to read more about this model please go
to the clinical chemistry of May last
year to summarize the IFC see reference
system is in place and used second
quality of hba1c sa is improved
dramatically and that led to a
paradigmatic hba1c is now also used for
diagnosis that led to rethinking of
quality and the task force made
constructed model for quality targets
that can be applied in individual
laboratory at a country level and at the
manufacturer level and once quality
targets are met we do what we have to do
we have achieved optimum quality and
that's optimum for use for diagnosis
thank you for your attention Thank You
professor John and dr. y-cam for your
presentations we're not ready for the
Q&A session as a quick reminder
questions can be sent via the green Q&A
button at the lower left of the
presentation window the try to answer as
many questions as you can and we do have
several questions already the first one
is what is the advantage of a standard
to a true reference material for patient
care if you can convert percent to
millimoles per mole and I think probably
both of our speakers will want to to
answer that question well cat well when
I start when I answer the advantage of
changing from the NGS be or any other
unit used in the world for example in
Japan or in Sweden or a manufacturer
value is that it's standardized and it's
same all over the world it's so
convenient when there would be only one
unit so that's the advantage for
patients that there's only one unit in
use all right I think it shouldn't be
confused the standard ation of the
method against the unit used to report
the method the value n standard asian is
vital to the same number or at least the
same result being produced in different
poetry's the unit was decided to change
from percent units to minimal form or by
different committee to the standard
action committee and that is because
percent is not a recognized unit of
measurement and in a meta logical system
you have to use recognized units of
measurement and the SI unit where
compares more two more was the one that
was agreed upon so don't get confused
the standard ation it
print to the terminology used to report
result thank you both next question is
the variability of hemoglobin a1c and
children greater than in adults there's
no biological reason that the number
will differ apart from the glucose
control glucose control in children is
far poorer that is in adults for obvious
reasons so the higher the glucose the
higher the dog near wouldn't see there
is evidence that our patients get older
hit be able to see values are higher for
the same level of glycemia the reasons
this is relatively unknown but that is
in the older individuals I think
tionally we know that the glycemic
control in children is slightly poorer
than those models at what time did you
want to respond as well I think hey Gary
gave a very good answer i have nothing
to add to that thank you Gary okay then
we'll go on to the next question what
would it explain that glucose is not
equal to hemoglobin a1c does that mean a
person a very life values of glucose but
normal a1c values the glucose is is not
lightness in its own right hemoglobin
a1c in a product of a reaction and
either hopefully try to point out that
the value of hemoglobin a1c in an
individual is reliant on a number of
factors which we hope will assume may be
constants but as we now know they're not
totally so in an individual same level
of glycemia in patients who have got a
variability in red cell survival or the
microenvironment hemoglobin a1c without
may be different it difficult to imagine
a very high glucose resulting in it
normal hemoglobin a1c they do relate to
each other but what I was trying to say
is that they're not the same and that
when you diagnose a patient the glucose
you potentially diagnosing a different
cohort of individuals to that you may
diagnosed in the dog near when you see
there's no evidence does he say one is
better than the other they are different
I agree with Gary that there is a
difference information from hba1c and
glucose I think the best information in
case of doubt is when you do both and
repeat it from time to time in case you
doubt about it there will be quite a
number of patients especially in elderly
people of around 60 years that are
borderline do they develop or don't they
develop hba1c and then it gives good
information and we should also keep in
mind that glucose just gives a picture
of today and that can be quite different
from tomorrow what hba1c gives an
integrated picture of a couple of months
so in my opinion there is different
information from it the best patient
care is when you do both thank you now a
very practical clinical question is it
recommended that pre-diabetic individual
say with an a1c percentile about 5.6 we
started on treatment I think it's
important to actually recommend they are
not diabetic I think I said first thing
to say that they have not fulfilled the
criteria for being identified and
labeled a diabetic but yes I think most
physicians around the world now would
recognize this pre-diabetes condition
and would it institute a degree of
lifestyle change so I
I think when we're looking to a
lifestyle change rather than treatment
per se but yes it is important that
these patients are identified and
changes are started to improve their
lifestyle I think in hba1c exceeding
five point six percent should ring bells
that things are not quite good as it
should be then you start at the lowest
level change lifestyles gary says lose
weight and exercise more and if that
doesn't work and hba1c remains high you
may think of starting therapy and what
exactly the flesh hole should be maybe
somewhere between six and six point five
percent between 44 and 48 millimoles per
mole can also be different from person
to person also depending on age I think
when a person is 90 years old you can be
less critical then when a person is 42
or something I think catch it right that
I think the important thing there is
that the present catalyst six point size
the patients already how significant
macro vastly disease by that point I
think 6.5 or 48 million was the mole
will be in them but they were have to be
revisited in the next few years I'm
possibly corrected to provide a better
diagnostic criteria the next question is
perhaps potentially contentious and it
is should anyone see those be reported
as millimoles per mole the SI units are
should that be reported as % a1c the NGS
p units well my preference is that we
use SI units like we use kilometres like
we use degrees celsius i am also in
favor of using millimoles per mo but for
me as european it's quite difficult to
tell the Americans that they should
change to Millie
oppa mo although they'd leave miles etc
so my preference is millimoles per mo
but in daily practice I'd have to simply
have to live with two units but my
preference clearly millimoles per mo for
it represents the true hba1c and there
is also a linear relationship with
glucose when glucose is zero hba1c in
IFC SI units is also 0 but when glucose
is zero hba1c in Angie's B units is 2.1
percent that 2.1 percent is Nam hba1c
reported as hba1c Gary I I think
slightly different to a cause of
European the British European I still
drive my car around the miles but I also
agree because that millimoles per mole
is the correct units to report in purely
because in metallurgical terms the scent
is not a recognized unit of measurement
percent is something which was used
because it described what we what we
measured and sent without able to see
against against totaled like hemoglobin
but in true terms we should report them
in molar terms and millimoles per mole
is the correct way of actually reporting
it but i agree with cars we have to be
pragmatic here and if people feel
comfortable percent units then it you
know we will not want to dictate what
people are reporting but in milling
Baltimore term there is a direct linear
relationship with Lee goes down to zero
thanks for those two very craftsman
responses we only have time for one more
question other questions can be answered
via email final question is are there
point-of-care testing devices available
for a 1c and how accurate and reliable
are they in comparison to the central
lab devices that I think you primarily
been speaking about today
there are in point of care devices
available and as I have seen and you
could see in my presentation some of
them perform quite well but there are
also reports of systems that do not
report well and even when it kept survey
you see that the performers of point of
care is quite good you should keep in
mind that it can make quite a difference
whether such a point-of-care instrument
is operated by a laboratory staff as
will be in the laboratories that
participate in the cap survey or when
it's operated in a doctor's office where
people are less experienced with
laboratory work and where it can be less
good Gary yes I think they were they
that there our number of devices about
as cows said and I think there were two
very good publications but in a lentes
in clinical chemistry over the last
couple of years which actually shows
that some devices are extremely good and
in many cases are actually as good as
laboratory methods with other methods
I've actually quite poor and should be
avoided totally so I would advise you
reading daughter Linda's paper in
clinical chemistry two papers and
published over the last two the three
years that concludes our Q&A session and
thank you again to both of our speakers
professor John and dr. why camp is also
a sponsor Emma diagnostics for making
this webinar possible this is a reminder
you can get free continuing education
credits by clicking on the link at the
bottom of your screen today's webcast
will be available for on-demand viewing
to the 19th may 2016 you will receive an
email alerting you when it's available
on demand and posted on lab routes comm
you're welcome to for this announcement
Johnny colleagues who weren't able to
join in today thanks again for logging
on and participating in today's webcast
see you next time